[موسيقى]
ينتشره في ملعب انجلترا الرياض تحتضن ضرب
الغضب وطفل يسرق مضرب نادال المفضل هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
بشده انجلترا بعد قيامه فريق من الصحيفه
خلال مباراه
مانشسترده في 80% من دوره المياه في ملعب
توتنهام فورد كما تم ايقاف العديد من
المشجعين بعد تناولهم مخدرات من الدرجه
الاولى خلال مباراتين
الامطار غدا الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
بالضبط الى استاد الملك فهد الذي سيحتضرر
السوبر الايطالي بين انكر وميلان حسابات
الناديين على السوشيال ميديا قد نشرت صور
التدريبات وصور اللاعبين والمدربين مع
الجماهير وتعدوا هذه المره الثالثه التي
يقام فيها السوبر الايطالي في العاصمه
الرياض بعد نسخته 2018/2019
وفي العاصمه الاماراتيه ابو ظبي وصل فريق
بوكا جونيورز الى مدينه العين التي ستحتضن
السوبر الارجنتينيه
المباراه يوم الجمعه على ستاد هزاع بن زيد
الخاصه بنادي العين كما تعد هذه المره
الاولى التي يلعب فيها السوبر الارجنتيني
خارج الدوله اللاتينيه
ابو ظبي ايضا مباريات السوبر الارجنتيني
في السنوات المقبله
[موسيقى]
تعرض نجمه الاسراف لموقف غريب وطريق بعدما
سرق احد جميع الكرات المضرب المفضل للاعب
الاسباني واكتشف نادال خلال المباراه
الجوله الاولى من بطوله استراليا للتنس
اختفاء مضرب به كما تسبب في توقف المباراه
كونها اثار على ايجاد مضربهم المفضل قبل
ان يكتشف انه سرق وقدم اعتذاره للحكم
والمنظمين
[موسيقى]